hachimachi that middle class famous tour
is in full swing gipperino you ain't
lying fatty it's a live comedy show we
play a little ayg with the crowd great
way to introduce people to the show
bring the squad come out and see us
we're coming baby yeah gang these
tickets are selling quickly uh so make
sure you get your tickets we're coming
in we're going to be red bank new jersey
then we're going to seattle portland all
in august then in september we're going
kansas city springfield st louis then
we're going down into nashville hitting
indy coming home to philly baby the
chicken's got to come home to roost yeah
then we're hitting providence rhode
island up there to bean town get those
tickets let's go welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out they go to be classy or
they're just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host holy coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at aunt
tony's basement she's away okay she's at
eagles camp okay talking [ __ ] hoping
that one of them takes a swing at her
she got a couple of dollars coming her
way my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me he is the ceo of are
you garbage he's an international
businessman he's the prince of park
avenue but always the king of the
boardwalk baby give it up for kj kevin
james ryan hey gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate view
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube as you know those numbers are
true cooking and then obviously the
greatest goddamn website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage check it
the [ __ ] out it's a party over there and
get tickets to a live show shows the
show now philly sold out seattle sold
out boston is about to go get them
tickies come see us gang and having a
nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good he works the ones and twos
he crosses the d's and he dots the eyes
give it up for t-bone mcmuffin toby
mcmullen everybody what up dudes what up
t-bone oh man long days in the building
yeah daddy's been here in here about 10
minutes i'm ready to buy a bunker here
these kids have it this kid's in one
today baby what are you guys gonna admit
that aunt tony doesn't live here i was
upstairs johnny i came down
you guys are running some sort of tax
scam here this guy's fake news you guys
don't want to pay the property taxes on
this place aunt doody left the family
and she's [ __ ] a guy named derek she
lives on the other side of the tracks
and these guys have built the studio
here so they don't got to pay [ __ ]
taxes
listen we're still getting her it's in
tutti's name but she's not here
i know the [ __ ] scam it's a straw
purchase on the house yeah i know how
you sound yeah we got our social
security checks coming in what do you
want from us she died 18 years ago
gang we couldn't be more excited to have
our incredibly and i mean [ __ ]
incredibly special guests back with us
again today at this point you know him
as the host of long days he's got a
special out right now that's tearing up
the [ __ ] charts called mom love do
yourself a favor go over to youtube and
check it out give it up for the one the
only giannis pappas yeah
thanks for having me thanks for you know
thanks for having me i drove all the way
out here south jers
[Laughter]
also i don't know i don't like to
disrespect mr louis c.k you called us
the wawa
i thought that was i thought that's a
good nickname that's great fantastic
thing although what i said on the last
episode uh foley was like uh he he tried
to study oh you did you were like wawa
brothers you didn't like the twins
guys
you didn't want to be related to him i
am getting fatter by trump just being in
a business
we all kind of are like in between sizes
it's tough sure you float a lot what are
you rocking what are you a large xl i'm
in between a lard and an extra large
really which is embarrassing do you have
to do some t-shirts in the morning you
get up they're fresh out of the out of
the laundry you got to do this
you're doing that you're doing a little
shake before you put the head in you do
a little pop i put them on first and uh
i if it's a large i try to stretch it
and see if it works look in the mirror
from the profile and then i take it off
okay if you look at the bed there's just
a lot of
large is just thrown on the bed until i
find one that fits i'm in between i'm at
the point where i have to like crack
open a ten pack of t-shirts
and try each one off i love that to make
sure
i either look like i'm wearing a leotard
or
i look like i'm a black guy going to a
barbecue
it's like a [ __ ] black spot
just too big or too small
you never know what day they were made
at the factory you know what i mean it
could have been made on a wednesday get
you all jammed up
shopping at t.j.maxx everything's all
[ __ ] up in size who's who's doing that
for you up there did you everybody knows
beautiful family yeah suburban life yeah
well taken care of out there yeah are
you picking up those teas or does the
misses do that kind of stuff this is
picks up those two she picks it all up
yeah when's the last time you were
clothes shopping last time i was close
sh i always close shop you go and get
like you you'll go and pick up you get
some nice pieces yeah he buys pieces
jani does i go socks and undies i go
socks of my socks i only go to
uh what's it called the the asian store
no the asian one right uh with the asian
rice um
fuji no oh god what all these yeah
that's german supermarket i go to that
one or the swedish one fuji no no
there's that's the famous one oh uniqlo
unicorn hey i go to unicorn still
rocking unicloud oh either unicolor or
go to the swedish joint i just can't
think of the name right now
a lot of meatballs and get yourself a
dresser
what's the famous cheap one the sw it's
a swedish store that's where i get all
my socks and they're like is he talking
to him yeah like
you guys when you when you know when you
when he finds it when toby's swedish
you're going to know the story and
you're not going to know who's the lemon
not lululemon pj masks you're expensive
no
really god what is it no i don't think
it exists it's a virgin old navy it's a
scandinavian version of old navy is it
scandinavian or swedish man h m well
sweden is in scandinavia yeah yeah it's
got you there got you there toby johnny
globes over here
so dumb yeah i got groot and choden [ __ ]
h m h m we already just said h m how the
[ __ ] is that swedish it's swedish i
think he's right it is yeah i wouldn't
call that okay
i thought you were talking about like
some sort of boutique type thing it's
from sweden he's right i know it is it
is h m h m so i get my socks from h
really they're too bad they're not good
they they don't last that's why i just
keep buying them you gotta keep you
gotta really they have you know they're
bad because they're by the checkout yeah
i just take them off i throw you guys
know i'd like to throw a lot of things
in the fire pit god my fire pit is ready
for winter
i love it it's got diapers in there it's
got h m socks second it drops below 72.
crank it up baby
get rid of these tees that's one thing i
enjoy about adulthood and having a
little bit of money is i am very
reckless well i'll i'll grab a [ __ ]
nine pack of socks underwear on the way
home and throw everything i got out yeah
i'm constantly [ __ ] rotating that
stock yeah fresh in there yeah not one
[ __ ] not not one expiration date on
my own
i keep it moving i like that we slipped
in got a little money i like that right
there and it's not a lot i got socks and
t-shirt buddy baby hit me up i like we
started this podcast he's got you've
been going to a hair stylist
no your hair looks good right now it's
been using sun in it and it looks bad
oh is it sudden dude it's bad
that's all sunny that's all hydrogen
peroxide right there oh it's sun in it i
thought it looks good it looks pretty
good sun in pretty classy
it's all right that's for like i don't
use sun and i use sun bum i was being
facetious
whenever you grab hair product from cvs
you know yeah that's real dirtbag
do-it-yourself do-it-yourself healthcare
uh haircare that's real fugitive style
i've been debating this yeah you're
shaving you're shaving your face in a
public bathroom yeah
he's just murdered your wife yeah he's
in a gas station bathroom rubbing water
on his face like that cliche movie scene
and then he's got sun in in there
changes look hide from the cops would
you uh would you ever dabble in uh
little just for gray would you ever just
for men no never people think i dye my
hair because you know i'm in my 40s so
they're like how's your hair look that
good i'm like greek don't leak baby yeah
what are you going to do black don't
crack greek don't worry you got the gray
here i got it a lot of people get it
right here like the gray or red i've
been debating dipping into this oh it's
gonna look so bad dude the even the guy
on the box looks bad
if they can't get the box right you're
gonna stay in the chair billy mays
looked pretty good with it i'll be
honest with you
hernandez uses it how big can it be oh
no no no don't do it because it's like
the color is always two jets it's black
yes it's two not what it's too not
natural yeah
you look like uh you look like the
undertaker's manager
looks painted on but you got very little
i know but it's it's it's you just look
like you did a couple lines of coke and
mist
powdered doughnuts on the way here
i tried to make it a little you know
he's looking slimmer he is he's great
you're looking
yeah yeah yeah that was a stunt double
but still
when he was on the treadmill did you
have nine one on on dial that's what i
said i said was there an emt outside
i got a lot of messages of encouragement
for that but i also got a handful of
messages from uh people in the personal
training is like yo knock that [ __ ] off
i got one too it's like you gotta knock
that cheek somebody save him i'm like
he's got a higher trainer i guess
here's the thing there's like a hot guy
in you like uh a block of marble yeah
yeah you're like a michelangelo
statue
ready to come out i got the little
pee-pee i can tell you that
david wasn't rocking anything little
light switch you chip away a little bit
there's a [ __ ] hot guy in there i'm
working on it i'm trying yeah you got
good face symmetry thank you
sounds like a greek dessert what are you
talking about
two symmetries how was dinner the
symmetry was a little cold i'm the only
guy without cte who talks like he has
cte that's weird i mean maybe i do have
it are you outside linebacker
no i just words don't come out right i'm
starting to get to that point too i'm
missing a lot of stuff yeah yeah yeah i
think things aren't working 100 up there
i think i got a little bit though yeah a
couple years couple tell you i mean we
get you know wheelchair will push you up
you know i'll call you fat call you old
catch the checks call the [ __ ] day i
want to get on that testosterone
[Laughter]
i want that in stem cells yeah you
should deal with those yeah you're one
of those guys who's going to go full
whatever they got you're going to take
[ __ ] yeah let's go yeah and if i make it
the [ __ ] 80 i'm [ __ ] definitely
80. god the bar is low
life expected he's 77 average now really
2022 yeah yeah he's i mean his but his
organs have lived a tough couple of
years yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're
right you're right yeah tough couple of
years he's still on the heaters too are
you still smoking what do you guys call
them burning bernies
i asked someone we were at a club or
whatever two months ago i'm like yanni
you you like a cocktail you drink ghosts
oh you know what i'm into scbd
they're really getting in and i see me
dig what are you doing anything i'll do
it anytime anywhere
yeah are you still taking that i love
cbd it works for me where are you where
are you
where are you picking it up so earnestly
who am i picking it up he's working
fields dot com slash garbage i got
[ __ ]
i got a podcast they send it to me what
do you think i'm advertising you think
i'm doing mercedes-benz
i thought you had a plug up there in
sleepy hollow guys this podcast is
brought to you by
let's go yeah re-plug toby cut that
unless i see some weight moving into the
[ __ ] studio send me some sticky let's
do it so you're still you taking them in
the morning i just watch them i'll take
them at night do you do you gummy or
what are you doing are you smoking it i
ta she because like i i'm a guy who has
like uh i have like periods of intense
anxiety and then i get over it i'm good
for a long time
and it hits me back
so myself i'm here's how here's how
anxious i am
i'm anxious to take the remedy to my
anxiety like
gives me more anxiety so here's what i
do now and this also works for me um
you're a different kind of crazy dude
my uh you know i have a psychiatrist and
i only really see him for like he'll
just give me like a refill right
and so klonopins right okay after my
covert thing i had like you know a
little anxiety thing i took three of
them to get me sleeping again and that's
all i took that's all i took even though
i was supposed to take two a day i only
took three and then i kept the bottle
and then it gave me comfort to have it
to have the big thing
you have the parachute yeah you're
falling out of the plane you have the
package i got you so now what i do is
i'm feeling anxious i just put the
bottle
on the nightstand and i stare at it
that's like
that's like a dry drunk that's what
that's what a guy who never went to aaa
does just stares at a bottle of jackets
i'm like i've gotten to the point now
where i just hug it like a teddy bear
and i fall asleep
this guy's got issues but i don't take
him i don't take him because i'm too
anxious to take him sure you know
because i hear oh yeah what's gonna
happen get hooked but it works does it
knock you out when you take them they're
good
they're good that and a half a glass of
salty unblocked cbd can kick rocks
you're calling the [ __ ] heavy hitters
i love about people it's like you know
the pharmaceutical industry comes up
with something like that everyone's all
on board they come up with a vaccine
they're like we don't trust these
[ __ ] guys give me the thing that
makes me forget my day
[Laughter]
give me 14 klonopins but keep that
[ __ ] vaccine away from me i'm putting
that poison in my body let's go these
people want me at home not working
you got any vacations yeah i was going
to say how's this
looking like yeah i saw you you and your
you and your lady yeah very attractive
you i see a beautiful couple beautiful
things you try to reach her
level you do like the smokey are you
squinting your eyes you do a little duck
face a little bit she uh she makes me
look more successful than i am yeah yeah
yeah good looking dude come on well good
looking dudes pass peek no you're not
pissed i don't know you sometimes you
should get some shoulders
good past peak i got a gut as i've
gotten older my eyes have kind of
kind of like there's a gravitational
pull for my nose it's kind of pulling
them together johnny cyclops
look at me you look at me my in my only
one eye
how do you put this guy back in the oven
yeah they call me cozy eye yanny
so that's why i usually like to wear
glasses because it frames it gives off
the illusion that it frames the eyes and
pulls them apart gotcha yeah what do you
what has peak what do you do with the
brows is there any maintenance going on
up there yeah that's a you got to go see
the indians first
for sure yeah i stopped by them you do
that in the city are you doing them all
yeah
yeah you are no you're out of trash no
you're not your yacht is possible you
don't know you're not sitting in the
middle of the mall you're getting your
eyes threaded in the middle of a [ __ ]
where do you think they're located
they're not in barneys
there's no [ __ ] where do you think
you go to get threatened you're either
going into a converted bodega true right
but the mall's a tough one you're out
there just stretched out i'm [ __ ] out
there i'm [ __ ] happy to the
cheesecake
guys
that's nuts and a line of ladies with
short haircuts and neck fat it's me i'm
third in line behind a couple of
housewives and i sit down with they say
we got a greek and four of them come
over
and because these things [ __ ] if i
don't manicure them they turn into
caterpillars that turn into butterflies
and fly off my face
this is how you can spot a greek it's
the eyebrows yeah big eyebrows
my theory is because we used to uh you
know toil the soil what did it tell
kill so i think you know how like
baseball players put the black under
here i think this actually evolutionary
gotcha get the sun out of my eyes and uh
you know so that's that plus you give a
mean look to the turks when they come by
yeah it gives you like give one of those
get real evil give them the stink guys
yeah give them those do you have a gal
you go to or just whoever's up next
whoever's up next no yeah i don't i
don't you know do you do that at the
barber do you have a guy or a girl that
you go to who does
my mother
your mother-in-law it's a tough thing
though that's a tough thing that's still
going on doesn't watch his pot yeah it's
a tough it's a hard thing to it's hard
you know the haircuts are a little
inconsistent i hope she doesn't watch
they're a little inconsistent depends on
the colonoscopy and i'm in the
entertainment business so it's like i
can't there's something like once in a
while like it she'll just give me it
looks like i'm it should be at my
brother's school the haircut you know my
brother's special needs looks like
there's a van pulling up to take me to
bowling sometimes so
i went and i snuck and i got one uh-huh
i i got one from a guy now and like
this is could be the guy is this a
regular does she usually i don't want to
say he's the one but he couldn't
i did blow him
it's an uncomfortable thing with barbers
like if you get one
and then like he gives you the card and
then you know then you want to go to the
same spot especially where i live
there's very few options i can't just i
can't cheat on them now i feel like
we're in a relationship sure i can't go
to another guy with him looking at me
when you do it's over yeah i had that
same situation with the barber down the
street because i went in there one day
and it was almost seven he had one guy
in the chair but i'd been going to them
[ __ ] breaking them off [ __ ] every
couple of weeks greasing them he's like
he's like he's like you got to come back
tomorrow and i'm leaving ah [ __ ] you and
i was [ __ ] out and every time i walk
by with a fresh cut i see him [ __ ]
looking at
playing our old songs there's that guy
who used to break my chair
he don't come around no more and give me
three bucks do you feel weird about it
or you just own it i own it yeah but i
but i know that i know there's uh you
know there's there's a thing they're
actually twins
yeah it's it's two little russian twins
they're twins yeah they're twins and
they've got different spots no no they
don't they own no no no i'm not always
right i'm not a home wrecker what the
[ __ ]
jesus you broke up a family oh yeah that
happened and all that happened yeah
[ __ ] your brother too
oh so they're in the same spot yeah and
now you go to the oh yeah you can always
claim you thought he's the other one
whatever dude i had a guy i went in just
recently and he cut my hair i'm not i
don't have the confidence to go i'm
waiting for steve now yours is a quick
cut
in the car you're going you're going hey
guy we're out here
go light up here my friend easy
but he gave me i get i so i get chopped
jobs because i don't have the confidence
to say i'm waiting for mark or whoever
right right so i always get the rookie i
get the rookie because no one wants them
and i feel bad for them really nice guy
get the old guy playing checkers
i went up and he chopped me up pretty
bad it grew in better a couple days
later and then i went again to and i got
[ __ ] the guy again yeah so i sit down
and he's i see his on his face in the
mirror he is disgusted by my haircut
he's like
who did this right like he goes where'd
you get this done i'm like i had to
break his heart and tell him he sucked
i'm like you did it six weeks ago you
stink
it's tough it's tough and i'm one of
those guys when i get a cut i don't like
the conversation
i want nothing to do yeah i'm like when
i when they sp it's like an uber driver
when i find out they speak english i'm
like
i love when you get a new uber driver
and you just see like a long name
and you're like thank god they got two
masks on yeah and they got that plastic
thing there the plastic is in my own
little world back there yeah it's like
dude i got a limo i'm here to scroll my
phone maybe before we had phones ken
let's talk about established titles baby
i'm a goddamn land owner show me some
respect that's lord kippy to you we're
gonna be going to war in a couple of
years
oh man trench warfare my plot of land
versus your plot of land let's do it
gang as you know scottish custom if
you're a landowner you get referred to
as a lord or a lady okay he's a lady i'm
a lord
do yourself a favor you can have a lot
of fun establish titles you can buy a
little piece of property over there in
scotland helps reserves the uh the uh
scottish woodlands scottish woodlands
over there all right it's very fun can
actually own just a square foot yeah and
be a lord or a lady
it's a good time you should know it it's
a good time it's a great gift title
packs give you at least one square foot
of dedicated land on private estate in
edelston scotland an official
certificate with a crest i got one they
sent it check out the picture
look at that uh you're not buying stars
some [ __ ] out there in the galaxy
you're never gonna see we're talking
about hardcore real estate
i'm going to go over there this summer
start a fight with the neighbor
get your tree off my get your leaves off
my yard
uh you can officially change your name
because the bald head you can officially
change your name to lord of lady and
then you can use that name on credit
cards plane tickets oh my gosh oh that
should have shot
pre-check lord kippy's coming in holy
[ __ ] i guess he's just gonna be orlando
oh
established titles baby you're the [ __ ]
i'll get my license changed established
is running a massive sale call me sir
god damn it plus use the code garbage
and get additional percent 10 off that's
use the code garbage get an additional
10 off go to establishtitles.com garbage
to get your gifts now do it
gang ru garbage is brought to you by
freeze pipe uh-huh listen let me tell
you something someone open a window in
here cause it's a little chilly
nobody getting that hot air in your
lungs is no good you freeze it you pack
it and you rip it and you have a good
time do yourself a favor pick up a
freeze pipe save your lungs a little bit
yeah the hot smoke passes through the
frozen piece cooling down the smoke as
you inhale they smoke so cold they'll be
calling you chilly willy yeah penguin
bones uh-huh they sent one to us i feel
like double 07 when this thing showed up
i opened up a case alarms went off it
was a whole nine yard this thing comes
in comes in real tight real cool makes
you feel like a cool cat me and the long
hair got into that pretty quick
easy does it this is a family show
freeze pipe is non-toxic freezes faster
than water and stays frozen longer
freeze pipe cools down the smoke by
hundreds of degrees hundreds of degrees
that's what they're doing over there
this is this is crazy technology we're
talking about freeze pipe is going to
take care of the bozos and the homies
out there the freak go to the freeze
pipe.com use code garbage to save 10 off
your first order get yourself a new bong
pipe or bubbler today that's the
pipe
t-h-e
com code garbage save 10 do it yeah you
know what we're talking about back to
the show
what was that have you taken a taxi
recently a proper taxi got in plea threw
your hand in the air said i'm going to
queen yeah some city i was in where was
i just i got in a taxi those are weird
montreal i got a taxi in montreal
because there was no ubers late at night
because you know
they're full-on socialists so why try to
make money you know shut it down yeah i
mean nobody's working up there that's
why everyone's losing their bags the
airlines are shutting off he was posting
pictures like you were on your honeymoon
dude you were like swinging around light
posts and stuff
i love this city like damn yani makes me
want to go to montreal they're
they're up there they're wild the french
are up there while dude i've never been
they just passed the bill bill 96
straight out of kovacs
he's already been there a weekend
i was here three weeks i'm on the city
council at this point
like i was there soon gets involved
locally yeah i was i was there think
globally act locally it's got a
grassroots effort going on up there in
montreal dude i was uh so i was there so
long like how the [ __ ] would you know
what bills they got that's what what are
you reading the paper up there yes yeah
i read about it and uh i was doing the
culture did just for the culture show
okay formerly known as the ethnic show
mm-hmm but they changed it to just for
the culture yeah because ethnic was
somebody considered derogatory slur
that's wild these i love the ethnic show
and you went up what is what greek i
would have missed yeah which is like
yeah whitey
yeah it's like you know we're kind of
like we get kind of like this thing
greeks we're like is he white is he not
he's greek he's kind of sure you know
um yeah so the bill 96. so anyway we had
to say i had this idea that like i
wanted he's nuts i wanted to call and
keep complaining to just for laughs
about the name of the show about like
anonymously sure just like start posting
and be like just for the culture until
they just had to call it show
come the show
your family's behind you wait and come
on we have dinner reservations
culture what about people who who have
two cultures or three cultures what do
you mean just for the culture that's
otherwising people who don't identify as
one
let me talk to andy kindler
i don't know he did a job
on the phone now
this state of the industry uh lasted
longer than it should have he should
have just got up there and been like
this is over good night
[Laughter]
tick tock isn't here google's not here
what are we doing
it's over
you don't want to talk to anyone else
let's grab a sex doll in some vr and get
the [ __ ] out of here yeah what are we
talking about i mean are you what are
you gonna i mean it's kind of a
different thing now but so bill 96 is um
[ __ ] man
bill 96 there you should have a picture
of water rings yeah
they um they want to make uh uh it
illegal okay to speak english so the
french are like crazy and it's passed
like unanimously so i mean that's an i'm
oversimplifying it but sure if you
immigrate schools
no it's more than that so if you
immigrate to
uh quebec you've got about six months to
learn french and if you don't like you
get deported what that's part of the law
damn you're a restaurant you're not
[ __ ] around have to be in french
uh they send out spies and they go to
your restaurant and if it's not you get
fined
yeah so they go hard you have to say
bonjour high you got to say the french
first bonjour boxes
they're big on it i'm a big french guy
though i like it french is nice
but it's like here listen look i know
the english and the french got a thing
right where they're constantly battling
but there's a little thing called
america okay usa and we're the neighbor
to the south and
they should be thankful that we're all
not speaking german right now okay
enough and that's because of guys who
speak english sure your little neighbor
to the south so how about a little
respect for the boys that stormed the
beach so you could run around shout out
to easy company so [ __ ] listen to me
the premier quebec pepe lipu
maybe an exception in that bill 96 that
says if you got an american passport we
look the other [ __ ] away if you say hi
because thank you that we're not
listening to german techno right now
we're [ __ ] hugo boss unis thanks to
the boys who stormed the beaches
now make sure i got ketchup with my
chicken fingers okay yeah nobody's fat
over there
they have regular type they got
regulations on the food yeah yeah oh
yeah of course core
high fructose corn syrup and ketchup gmo
like that same thing over in europe
[ __ ] real nice real all natural
they also don't wear deodorant though
either
it is what it is i was just down in
wildwood new jersey shout out maybe the
most american place no french down there
no there is not these they still serve
freedom fries down there it's like it's
like [ __ ] september 12 2001 down
there
they don't give a [ __ ] dude it's great
but on the boardwalk at 11 o'clock every
day on the boardwalk
everybody they play the national anthem
and everybody freezes hat off over the
heart and i was with my wife
who's german and she was like she didn't
i would lean on like it's a [ __ ]
america you better [ __ ] paint some
goddamn respect everybody who died for
this [ __ ] goddamn sam's pizzeria
right now
everybody stops hitting their girlfriend
for a second
when this is over you're [ __ ] dead
meanwhile the gravitron's still running
can't shut that off what are you kidding
me good clean american fun baby are you
gonna do anything would you have you
guys done anything this summer are you
gonna do anything
she came up and visited me for a couple
days while you were making prank phone
calls yeah
real real romantic guy yeah he's calling
bruce hills going like this just for the
culture show
um then we did a little fort lauderdale
what okay wait a minute let's see wait a
minute
did you fly from uh canada down to no
way okay we did that before we went to
fort lauderdale a couple days in fort
lauderdale nice did you see the weekend
or midweek we did a weekend weekend yeah
weekend off peak a little humid take the
kid no no kidding
a little human is an understatement yeah
yeah don't go in the summer to florida
but we did rates are good
yanni alligator arms four seasons was 50
bucks
take two seasons please i don't care how
many [ __ ] jellyfish are out there i
don't need the towels all right
yeah we did a little fort lauderdale
okay yeah i think it's a nice little
getaway because it's cheap
[Applause]
and what do you do when you get on it
you get the hotel save money
miami's hop skip and a jump that miami
is like
it's like crazy how expensive oh it's
nice they what they do now is they
include the tip and your bill in miami
yeah so because i heard you were coming
yeah yeah
bombas are coming again [ __ ] juice of
the bill is [ __ ] cheap and they don't
tell you so sometimes like people will
tip and it's already in there and then
you got to like you got to be hip to it
but fort lauderdale's none of that
10 across the board yeah kidding me fort
lauderdale's like going down to south
florida like it would be like going to
new york and just never leaving hoboken
sure yeah yeah yeah what uh what what
airline did you fly down uh i think we
did delta i got miles okay i got miles
okay you do the bump up you do busy no
and my wife wasn't happy about it
i don't do the bump up for three and
under really don't do it yeah i can as
long as i get an aisle seat i can handle
it okay i can handle three hours in
coach you were you were in an aisle seat
in the way where we should choke in my
pocket
i forget how tight he is
i am a little frugal you are i'm a
little frugal yeah yeah i'm not a
spender except for sneakers but uh you
know so you were in the aisle where
where was the dame at where was mrs
papa's we had a middle six rows back she
was on the red eye that night
yeah she was on standby she didn't take
another flight they were offering 500
bucks so i gave it to her i'll get down
there and turn the air on get the room
nice and cold i'll see you in six hours
i'll get down there and negotiate with
the front desk oh i uh she got a child
discount god knows she's young enough
says your daughter coming on flight say
yeah yeah set a wing she's something
taking a picture with the captain
yeah no she we hadn't we had a middle
seat and um and a a window i usually do
aisle but the only seats that are
available in coach who takes the window
you do it was supposed to be me because
i don't like sitting next to the guy
because she's smaller sure of course you
know it's like when you sit in coach and
you and you get you got to work as a
team to make both people's most
conscious there's only two things you
want to see coming into that middle c
i know i hate to say it i don't know you
want to see asian or you want to see
woman
those are the two they're kind of
usually smaller smaller frames and
asians just polite about space they're
just a little more like civilized about
it you know the americans are kind of
like
gotta like you know flop out man spread
i know i've ruined some flights for
people for sure i'm aware of that yeah
for sure and everybody's [ __ ] judging
me the second i get on there and then
you fall asleep and you're like
[Laughter]
sounds like a blowtorch
i got training day blasting
i'm at the i'm at the point now i think
i said this but they don't you know they
come by
with three different snacks and they say
which one do you want right i just i i
get the [ __ ] sewing kit they just
there you go they just give them the oh
i get the i get the the almonds yeah i
get the uh the
granola bar which is actually pretty
banging on delta yeah and i get the
cookies i get the best coffee and why's
that because i'm a big fat big so they
know
they just assumed
you called the head the airline said i
said listen
pretty good
we're trying to keep him around yeah no
he's been doing very well he looks like
you look great looks good
you look great that's not going to his
head at all yeah you got it you got to
slim down a little bit oh yeah yeah we
all do yeah of course
yeah we do fat court on the patreon
where we lay them in once a month
the scale's right there yeah it's for
goats
that's a veterinary scale
he's a [ __ ] steer going to slaughter
he's got a tag over here it says 322.
there's bugs flying around his head
oh that's uh
yeah and how he you're losing he's doing
good i'm losing making weight that's
making money
do you do it legitimately or are you
just [ __ ] getting a steam room
try to fool people trash bags running
around old wrestling days
no i'm doing it uh in the beginning yes
i was now were you a former wrestler i
was yeah see that's different though
former wrestlers and former football
players always struggle a little bit
with the weight afterwards right i dude
i was
here he's 60 years old i'm all [ __ ] up
i got ptsd what do you mean this season
just ended
but you know
he hasn't been on a wrestling mat in 28
years but you learn those weird things
right of like cutting and then putting
it on and then yeah all that unhealthy
[ __ ] i develop
this isn't an excuse i'm a fat pig and
it's all my fault at what point of
wrestling to eat 14 beats is a week
you had ptsd putting sandwiches terry
out he got a combo load before a game
yanni
i'm sorry mr whitmer
um i do have a very weird relationship
with food because it was i mean i'd go
like two weeks without eating yeah like
straight two weeks i get it dude you see
like a lot of former linemen and stuff
like that boxers they blow you so you
see buster douglas
douglas you can't compare him to buster
douglas though well a little bit
a little bit they have something in
common sure yeah oscar de la hoya is
poking up broken up a little bit too
yeah he's also doing a little bit of
blow yeah he's having a good time i like
that kid yeah he likes to party that's
all right kid likes to put through bruno
mars bruno mars gets knocked every like
third week for [ __ ] cocaine in his
bag yeah a kid likes to throw on
stockings once in a while big deal i'm
with it yeah what the [ __ ] he's still
tuning in high heels right yeah big deal
and a full fishnet suit yeah that's
weird good looking kid like that down in
miami having a good time yeah the
[ __ ] yaks going around let's get
[ __ ] weird what do we do he'll still
knock you the [ __ ] out yeah i don't care
what kind of halter top he's wearing
yeah [ __ ] putting your lights out you
ever noticed like the guys the guys who
can fight her they
are really tough or just more okay like
they just kind of like yeah they're more
okay with that yeah yeah yeah well it's
like we try to be masculine to prove
that we're tough and we're not right so
it's like it's a it's they know they
have nothing to prove right like i'll
get a little freaky yeah yeah it's
almost like you get so masculine it
almost comes out to the other side like
a pac-man game yeah yeah there's only so
far you can go yeah you come back around
and start putting on a pair of pumps
yeah that's what i'm talking about i got
my lipstick in my purse ready to [ __ ]
party but no i'm taking this i'm taking
it seriously and trying to uh adjust all
my habits and stuff yeah yeah looks you
look good but i was i was fooling him a
little bit yeah
yeah i was i was not well maybe not he
wasn't i was sucking weight yeah i would
say the first month
i went i went like yeah cause it's like
ptsd for you now you feel like you're
back in your wrestling days where you
got to make weight yeah or else uh your
podcast partner [ __ ] makes fun of you
yeah
no he owes me money oh it's a money
thing
[Laughter]
uh that's what the youtube comments are
yelling out right about now
yeah i pulled out a couple of pounds
what up
yeah my hair's falling out i know
uh yeah i gotta i gotta tighten it up as
well yeah but your hair is your hair's
pretty is holding on for your age it's
holding yeah yeah
other pictures you look weird with hair
yeah okay it looks strange yeah you look
at an old substitute teacher yeah i like
it now you got a little bruce wilson you
button up your shirt it is distracting
me for sure
i feel like we're in boca right now
you and yanni in fort lauderdale
stiffened someone on a ticket
that hector tudy's already on there you
do that shirt with that hat just looks
like you're like in cancun on in an
all-inclusive from south jersey
yeah you put on the i sat through the
timeshare pitch yeah i'm living it up
living it up for three days
ah i [ __ ] like it yeah the longer you
you i lived in miami for a year and
every month you go one more button down
sure you can tell how long someone's
lived in miami by how many buttons yeah
that's what i want yeah never put on a
pair of pants again just go shorts and
one of these things yeah what's the
what's the the cuban one uh guayavera
what are they called the cuban shirts
with the pockets
uh that's a cheese you know what i'm
talking about they they got the the two
pockets that go down they're like like
barber shirts i think you were i know
it's a white linen shirt that has the
four pockets guayabera yeah
close enough yeah this is the culture
show yeah it's just a just for the
culture
get a little red cena in here [ __ ]
make it complete
yeah of course you know tina of course
i'm not saying greek wine greek wine
tastes like pineapple yeah waiting to
[ __ ] shove that in the conversation a
couple years
how do you know that i worked at a greek
restaurant ah yeah shout out to snack
tavern in the west village
delicious fantastic i never heard of
that one it's called snack snack taverna
phenomenal yeah phenomenal yeah is it
like more taverna food like kind of home
cooking kind of yeah or is it fancy no
it's it's it's a tongue cooking nice
neighborhood spot yeah breakfast with
brunch is amazing yeah really really
good but that's why i learned all that
stuff and fell in love with [ __ ]
greek food down here it's great
we got they said that we got the best
diet mediterranean diet there's true
cheese
cheese is phenomenal lowest fat
i found out about
[Laughter]
how did a guy memorize the menu so fast
we got a 86 the left side of the menu
yeah good stuff little domades 11 ice
cream [ __ ] good [ __ ] there you go
yeah do you entertain at the house at
all this summer we yeah we haven't we
got to redo the back kip how about that
helix love that helix baby i masturbated
in one this morning hey that's a top
quality company right there i'll tell
you that right now what do you want to
do you want to go to the mattress store
and walk around oh know what i want or
you want to take a quiz online find out
what kind of mattress is best for you in
about two minutes and get your mattress
delivered to your door you tell me what
you want to do bozo huh you want to be
pulling it like kippy in his apartment
or wandering around some [ __ ] bozo
mattress store yeah helix is fantastic
me and the lady got matched with the uh
twilight mattress loved it so much
upgraded to a king baby oh yeah it's the
best sleep of your life if you're out
there you're sleeping on you know a
mattress that someone died in the dog
peed on used peed on it's like done you
found it
because your roommate moved out so you
took his bed knocked that [ __ ] off get
it fresh get a good mattress i'm telling
you it's fantastic i love it uh helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to helixsleep.com
with helix better sleep starts now do it
okay let's talk about mint mobile oh
mint mobile mobile men mobile let's talk
about mint mobile and i want you to hear
me loud and clear uh-huh cause that's
the way you're gonna hear it on min
mobile and you know what else you're not
getting jacked by some long-term
contract you're not getting a bunch of
hidden fees 15 beans a month 15 bucks
out the door and let me tell you who's
got the stamp of approval on that who's
that patty patty's all over twitch yeah
switch yo what's this mint mode keep
hearing about this yeah there's got to
be a catch it's too good to be true it
ain't patty it's not i'm telling you
that right now switched over what's the
catch uh there is none
uh mint mobile secret sauces they were
the first company sell wireless service
online only they cut out the cost of
retail stores they're not paying rent on
every goddamn corner in new york city
philadelphia chicago los angeles there
you go no they cut out all the research
retail stores pass those sweet savings
directly on to you 15 bucks 15 bucks for
anyone who hates their phone bill mint
mobile offers premium wireless for just
15 clams a month look at it uh gives you
the best rate whether you're buying one
or for a family and mint family started
just two lines new age family that's
what i like yeah use your own phone with
any mint mobile plan
and keep the same number along with all
your existing contacts switch to mint
mobile get premium wireless started just
15 bucks listen to get this plan for
just 15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped directly to your door for free
go to mint mobile.com garbage that's
mintmobile.com garbage cart your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com back to that show there
back to the show the back doesn't look
good we got chairs on grass
oh yeah we got chairs on grass go to
poland what are you doing pools that's a
that's a cold hundred k 150 k then you
gotta get insurance you gotta put a
fence around but then you're saving
money on the florida trips and mon you
don't gotta go anywhere you got the
whole spot there and here's the thing
you put in a pool everybody's coming to
you for the next 20 years yeah i don't
know everybody's coming together the
neighbors kids are [ __ ] showing up in
my backyard i'm seeing them on the pool
hopping i'm seeing them you know i'm
seeing movement on the google cameras
i'm going out there with my shotgun i
kill one of my neighbors kids all they
want to do is go to the pool the other
one drowns in there because they sneak
in i get sued it's a whole mess yeah you
saw your real fun guy
hey let me try one of those kalona pins
take the edges holy [ __ ]
man that was a dark twist it's not
stranger things relax
and he said that like it's all he's
lived all of that emotionally i do the
same thing pools are headaches i know
the insurance is huge what'd you do
above ground pool
you can't do that right yeah cause then
i won't i couldn't come on this podcast
without you guys calling me trash i got
an above ground pool
at the foley house yeah you're trash
he's like yeah yeah we have we have a
deck built around it so it's almost
in-ground
no it's not almo it's still four feet
above the ground it keeps you cool in
the summer yeah
it keeps you cool he keeps
in ground above ground now in a grove
ground pool is there any uh is there any
like space for a chair or you just hop
in the pool and then you go back inside
first of all it's unlike anything i've
ever seen yeah right
they've their whole backyard you've seen
karate kid right yeah you know how
miyagi had to have had the backyard
pimped out where it was all deck can't
picture it oh my my whole backyard
you're gonna sit there and tell me you
can't picture mr miyagi's deck right now
i can't yeah of course you can't that's
a wild bowl is it what do you mean very
popular movie
well what do you have you had the deck
attached to the pool so yeah he didn't
have a pool you walk out get a koi pond
his whole backyard is a deck is an
elevated deck the size of the pool got
it so you got to like step up
onto the deck and then the whole entire
backyard
is a deck and pool god there's not a
blade of grass anywhere got
so what i'm saying is so what you want
to also save on mowing there you go yeah
100 yeah so you got you got uh chairs on
grass you want to put a patio in there
yeah we got to do a little patio we
can't have the chairs on ground are we
talking those white plastic chairs what
kind of chairs are we talking about i
got one of those like just recliner ones
okay that rust up though when the
weather hits them they get rusty yeah
you get them on amazon you have the you
have the pads on you got to put the pads
out yeah you got to put this is there an
awning in the back i walk out how do i
walk out of your back we got we got
those umbrellas but that for some reason
you fill the bottom with water but they
always fall over and almost kill your
daughter
come on so now so in my backyard they're
just always down because whenever you
put them up the slightest gust of wind
will threaten threaten life yeah you got
to hook that up yeah you got a swing set
back there for the kid i got a swing set
just bought a new swing really yeah
metal or wood wood what what did you buy
one of those ones with the with the
three colors on top with the the
expensive ones no no it wasn't expensive
but it has a finish on that they stole
it from yeah the wood has a finish on it
though okay is it does it have like a
little hut that she can climb into it's
got uh little uh little monkey things
okay monkey bars uh it's got the monkey
bars got the rope thing okay okay we got
the we got the infant um swing seat in
the middle there you go okay then you
got uh you got the rock wall climb whoa
and as my daughter calls it we got the
big slide the big yellow baby big slide
is the sliding closed like the tube
no it goes straight down great it's not
a carnival cruise what the [ __ ]
who put that up
it wasn't me
no yeah a couple mexicans guys came
didn't like that yeah i don't even think
they had a screwdriver i just saw him
turn into his [ __ ] hands
they really knock it out dude they know
what they're doing yeah they knock it
out and i placed it just perfectly i
actually had to call versi over i was so
angry take a look at that i called them
over it was actually a funny thing
because while they were over putting it
up i was like a little
unsure of if i was putting it in the
right spot because it's a permanent
decision and i didn't want to cut off
any of the acreage is there concrete
involved no concrete's right hungry
everything's on grass that's a problem
okay yeah so people who are no i'm
saying don't you have to don't you have
to put it in concrete so it doesn't fall
over i thought so but those boys went
right into the dirt i think you should
go down enough yeah okay so but i was so
unsure of it like while they were
putting together i called versi up and
asked him to come over so he could like
help me get eyes on him you get some
eyes on it and it was funny when he
showed up too close together yeah
we needed eyes not eye on it
we needed more in my yard
[Laughter]
he's got it in the living room
so it's funny when he came over they
were working and he walks up the back
steps and he just goes no no that's no
good we're gonna have to put it back
hey he's got a helmet and a penny on
they turned around like what like and
he's like i'm just kidding yeah oh it's
[ __ ] right it was really funny it was
really weird oh what are you doing it's
not gonna work you gotta go back go back
go back
and they were all startled and stuff and
he's like i'm just kidding and everyone
pretended like they understood
yeah yeah yeah you get lunch for the
guys when they're doing water my wife's
big on that my wife and my mother-in-law
are big on that that's good they'll
offer you come here she's the club your
wife's classy i would presume a little
more classy yeah her and the her and my
mother-in-law are big on hydrating
whatever is working yeah they'll come
out plate full of stuff nice waters nice
yeah me i'm not so you don't even let
them use the bathroom yeah no they can't
go in the woods
i love to piss outside at night oh it's
the [ __ ] best best dude everyone says
let the [ __ ] wind touch your balls
yeah the only problem is it's real pitch
black where i live right because we're
in the country so um i always piss at
night the last time i take my dog out
every night i piss i just i always save
that piss for the outside problem is my
dog's also black
so what happened the other night was my
dog ran through my piss stream
pissed on my
you dog anybody about that you guys yeah
so you just let it rock you didn't go
inside saying you gotta watch it you
wipe them off i went through that with
dog wipe and uh we went about our
business but i peed on the dog accident
yeah yeah caught you know it's a
casualty anybody asked you were drinking
you hear me
you let the dog sleep in a bed i do let
the dog sleep in the bed yeah nice so
you pee on your dog and let him hop in
your bed yeah that night i did after i
wiped him down yeah yeah yeah so it's
you and the missus and the dog at the
foot of the bed we do the bed is the
only thing she's allowed on she's not
allowed on any of the couches or
anything really yeah i want to preserve
those couches those are good west elm
couches
is there plastic on them there's no
plastic
not yet
wait for the delivery yeah not yet you
know what the one thing you got to watch
with the um
with the jungle gym in the back yeah you
got to be careful with the landscapers
when they're weed whacking around that
yeah they're going to [ __ ] up the bottom
of the wood because they're just going
to z right around it hot tip i'll take
it yeah keep an eye on that so what do i
do i get it i'll just shoot him with a
water gun
i get the hose coming
uh maybe some plastic covers down there
at the bottom so that doesn't affect the
wood i assume that would bother you if
it did plastic covers on the wood like
so where the wood meets the ground yeah
they can't you can't mower that right so
they're gonna get it they're they're
gonna weed whack around those little
chips
i don't think it's that big of a problem
right i don't want to put any more
signage up that would be weird if
there's a sign going like please mind
please mind the paint chips you don't
have signs up at your house do you i got
the security sign up oh of course yeah
doesn't have the subscription for the
security but all you need is just a slow
motion wait you really you just gotta i
got the subscription you don't have to
be aware of dogs if i didn't i wouldn't
admit it just get some cycle out there
now i got the full works you gotta have
the full work sure these days i don't
know i live in new york
you know that's so wild to me i get
scared when i go out in the burbs now
too quiet i feel like i'm going to get
got yeah i mean i'm looking out the
windows and [ __ ] i don't i don't trust
it yeah you don't do that
yeah you ever seen anything weird back
there no just you know i've seen a fox i
seen uh any weird lights in the sky or
anything no but my neighbors did you
watch
two neighbors you see yeah they both saw
yeah did you tell us this already no
didn't tell them hold on a second yeah i
didn't lay it on me yeah neighborhood do
you believe them i believe them when was
this i believe i believe
they said they were sitting on the back
and they saw it go across probably your
umbrella
[Laughter]
was it leaking
water yeah it's just yanny pissing sorry
about that i just run it over there
sorry i freaking win just text that
thing
again
was this recently recently yeah what
around the fourth of july went over
their house and yeah they told me
they're probably fire were they boozing
no they were sitting the two of them
were sitting out in their backyard they
said and they saw it go across the sky
they called they called the police to
see if anyone else had called it in
nobody else had called it in or whatever
wow but i believe him holy i believe you
look a little different now when you're
out there you i'm hoping i go out there
hoping yeah you would you would would
you
want to see yes you would want to i
would want your anxiety would be able to
take it
ah
maybe it's a whole nother world of
[ __ ] things that can get you maybe
it's one of those things that like it's
a good idea and then when it happens
like i really wish i wasn't yeah i'd
have to kill myself you wouldn't kill
yourself yeah invite him in yeah if i
don't give him a warning
he's worried about his neighbors
drowning his imaginary pool he can't
take alien life forms you crazy you guys
are fully insured right
i can't have you on the property there's
been like tons of mass sightings in
westchester where like you know up in
the north around i'm moving to jersey
there's one famous one on the taconic in
like the 80s or something where like
thousands of people saw it and they all
got out of their cars they were looking
at it and they all said it was like the
size of a football field and it was just
silently moving across like thousands of
people saw it damn yeah and then there's
the one you can google in in arizona
where you can see of course the phoenix
lights yeah it's like a big ship just
move it pull it up toby yeah i mean it's
wild aliens exist of course
i don't know what it's doing i think
they might be jerking off to us because
they come they look down at us these
guys are [ __ ] bozos i mean what do
you do once you're done with internet
porn you're out right yeah so that's
really they come they check it out and
then they're out it's the only
explanation possible about it they're
only here for a short period of time i
mean 30 seconds to get your [ __ ]
weasel act and get out of here and
that's like their browser history their
commander's like where were you guys and
they clear the history of where they
were arizona yeah
we were over engaged
yeah yeah we
[Laughter]
i would love to watch a sci-fi movie
written and directed by goddess
the greek save the day at the end
setting the planet sleepy hollow all
right all right let's do a couple of
cues yeah we only got a couple minutes
left we got to get to some cues last
time we were here we don't even get the
cues we have such a good time we're
going to get to the questions
you can tell it's a good guess by how
quickly we always have fun with you guys
gang do yourselves a [ __ ] favor he's
got a special out right now called mom
love it's on youtube do yourself a
[ __ ] favor he's a killer you also
just got some big praise by one
sebastian means
sebastian louis two louis gave me some
big praise shout out to louie louie
sebastian you know what's up yeah uh i
really appreciate it that feels good
when you get that from uh from those
guys you know i say this all the time we
you know we we go back and forth when
i'm like you know i don't want to say in
the zone but when we're like going back
and forth
i feel like you
like even like my cadence i start i
start like almost doing you what do you
mean like on stage no no here oh here
you have mimicky
yeah a lot of
you're the og of it like the and i'm
going all right you know what i mean
like that thing the yani thing you know
what i'm talking about i'm i guess i
can't see myself so i'm not aware oh
it's [ __ ] it's it's ingrained by the
way you guys [ __ ] killed on that i
think we i think we had a great stand up
on the spot oh that was fantastic
[Applause]
we've talked about this on the show i
think one of my favorite nights in
comedy yeah yeah it was nice out it
wasn't too hot everybody's hanging
outside broken cigars
the whole lineup hung the whole show
yeah it was fun
he's the best it's a that's a scary
thing you go up there and you're like
all right what do you got for me like
now that i did it once i want to do it
again yeah cause you're like the bubbles
burst yeah you know i know i can do all
right now because i was like the first
one you're kind of like what how does
this go you know you just like you take
one and you run or you but you could
deflect them you don't like one you got
nothing you're like all right give me
another one yeah
you stink i hear what you said
i didn't hear what you said i heard
meatballs huh let's go anybody got any
ideas on my jokes already
anybody know my closer
somebody say sleep apnea machine all
right here we go
all right
um all right this one in the same vein
while we were just talking about this
was from mike ever had to chase a wild
animal out of your house
[Laughter]
uh
i had a bird in the fireplace scared the
[ __ ] out yeah we had bats yeah i've yeah
you know those um ground bees they
they're cicada bees they're cicada
killers cicada killers
so we have they always get in the house
those things are like birds dude yeah
when you hear them when you hear them
hit the window you're like they're like
bang crack it a little bit yeah so i had
test banging on the doors racking i had
the tennis racket a couple of those
mofos i killed two bats with a tennis
racket i didn't want to do it i was
young they were in the house what was i
going to do tennessee near them very
underrated very murdering weapon of
animals broad face face good swipe good
the air goes there's no resistance yeah
yeah and you hear it whack and they
[ __ ] go yeah they go and then the you
know that usually against they hit the
wall too like a pinball bang and you get
it twice
do those i don't know if those cicada
kills do they bite do they sting they
don't really [ __ ] with you they just
[ __ ] up your lawn they're what do you
mean like because they they they like to
burrow like close to pathways and stuff
how many of these things have you got
dude
in my life oh god they love my property
for some reason so what you also do is
you get the uh you'd rather have the
aliens yeah you get the poison you find
their holes and you smoke them out
you smoke them out like viet cong
hit him with some agent orange
you know it was a low-key amazing insect
killer
lint roller it's like a club that's a
glue trap dude oh i guess it'll stick on
him i like that dude that's like a black
jack yeah [ __ ] hit him over there
yeah like an old cop in the 20s
but you don't gotta
you don't got a wide
yeah you gotta you gotta find point you
gotta hit that yeah i'm accurate how
about this one
tape the lint roller onto the tennis
racquet there you go and have something
just talking crazy
then leave him out in the yard let his
boys see him this is what happens when
you come to the papa that's what happens
stay off my jungle gym i'll pay you
right now
damn dude cicada killer killers and of
course
new york it's always the big roaches
those big water bug joints you got him
up there too no no but when i was here
you know when you we kill them they
crunch
they say don't crunch them because it
like brings out more or whatever i
didn't even hear that it's like they
apparently they release some sort of
there's a old wives tale maybe they
release some sort of
chemical when they're killed when
they're smooshed oh they're like how are
you supposed to get rid of them i think
you asked them to leave i don't know
we have mushroom i don't give away i
used to drown them in alcohol too i had
i put alcohol in a spray bottle and i
would just oh yeah
i use we use bleach behind the thing
just to make sure and we we haven't had
them at all but this summer we've seen a
couple and the other night there was a
[ __ ] fatty daddy before i got home
and my girl's like i killed it but it
went under the rug and i smushed it dude
i get down on all fours i just got home
[ __ ] barely see i pulled back that
rug and this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
waiting for me i think he's an audio
dude not dead at all [ __ ] runs out
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] trying to kill it
the cat's [ __ ] running around those
things are [ __ ] scary they're big
dude they're big one thing i'm not
scared of at all is spiders i i showered
with one yesterday i was one in my
shower in the basement i just left them
i don't i don't i don't want to kill
them i like what they do no you're not
supposed to kill him i never killed him
yeah they they kill other insects
they've got sure yeah when they bite me
i don't care you know i just don't have
a fear of spiders i got weird other
fears but not spiders i showered when
the other night it was up there i was
looking at them the whole time that i
get if it's not you know encroaching on
like you know if you're not on the couch
and it
drops down the front was is he big he
was sizable
i mean if i if if it bit your daughter
that could be an issue yeah yeah yeah
that's the only thing but they do they
keep all those little bugs away they
keep them away yeah yeah keep them away
you just don't want too many of them
yeah they start mating yeah that's a
hangout for them no way jose i'm not
that scared of spiders daddy longlegs
they scare the [ __ ] at you yeah but
they're the most they're nothing
yeah it looks like tim burton made him i
don't like that [ __ ] dude i don't [ __ ]
with that [ __ ] daddy long legs i
don't like uh the
the praying mantises those things just
really yeah yeah
they'll [ __ ] you up they'll [ __ ] you up
too they bite yeah don't they leap too
yeah i feel like you like you're sitting
there looking like oh come over and then
next thing you know what's on your
[ __ ] grill but it's illegal to kill
them you can't kill them yeah okay
federal law
send me up the river
[Laughter]
detective shows up at your door knocked
on the door you honest made me do it i
swear
it starts swiping for fingerprints
15 hands yeah it's an easy crime to get
away with yeah
who's like yeah unless somebody's got a
flip on you real quick yeah you know
your wife's got someone's got a flip on
it what are you gonna tell us today
tough guy you got something yeah
i'd have my wife [ __ ] deported
[ __ ] turned me in
uh i just was from william first time
caller long time listener have you ever
owned an fbi shirt female body inspector
did you get caught up in that [ __ ] as a
kid what about uh uh what's the big dick
what's it called johnson yeah no
absolutely none of that i got none of
those uh you you win them out of state
fair shirt shout out to the live one
boardwalk man yeah no
yeah those are those are jersey shore
shirts right there yeah don't have any
of those anything airbrushed over at the
house
[Music]
you got a jean jacket says yani on the
back a little sunset
[Laughter]
no airbrush yeah
it's the worst quality of anything ever
yeah yeah i tell you what a nice faded
jean jacket with a nice airbrushing on
the back though i could see that coming
back yeah it's time to pull up it's
ironic it's bieber could wear that
there's only
one option right you have an airbrush
shirt like that you don't have a ba
if you have a shirt like that yeah you
don't have a ba yeah you have a ba or
you have a shirt like that airbrush is a
tough yeah it doesn't come with a degree
no no oh that's what you're talking
about i don't know what a substitute he
also doesn't have one
that's airbrushed a bachelor of arts
yeah yeah bachelor of art is that what
regular degrees are called what if you
didn't study arts then you get a bs or
uh bachelor of science bachelor of
science nice what do you have i got a
[ __ ] ba it's good for a high school
diploma kippy what do you got
yeah i have a ba in business yeah a ba
what about you t-bone i got a booming
independent business with you guys
i am an independent contractor no
student debt over here huh kick rocks
[ __ ]
the ba really is worthless yeah yeah you
got to get your master's yeah what are
you doing it's a real like it really is
just just it's like a high school
diploma again would you ever go back to
school just for yourself would you would
you ever take a master's program or
anything like that never
never what if you could live on campus
i'd become i'd be a squeegee guy before
i went back to [ __ ] school i hated
school did you ever teach comedy
whatever
johnny's close to it now
i got my wife making the signs right now
i'm looking at it i'm looking at spaces
here in tudis
yeah i'm like yeah let me see if i can
get a space so if they said hey you can
get your masters for free at like
florida state but you got to live there
on campus
in a dorm in a dorm now you get your own
apartment yeah i can't be a creepy guy
on creepy old guy on campus
getting his
back to school hanging out at the mixers
yeah you can't
no i think at this point it's sick or
swim right you can't go sure school no a
lot of people do it just you know just
for the further their education
yeah not me not me no i hated it too no
no i barely got my my degree you know
like school now should be for like if
you're becoming a doctor or an engineer
or you're getting into
like tech stuff sure other than that you
just google it
just google it youtube yeah youtube it
or google it you know or just get the
book and read yourself like like good
will hunting set
you know there's two things you don't do
that and the second thing you you spend
a hundred grand on education you get a
dollar fifty late fees yeah library how
you like them how do you like them
apples do you read
do i read yeah like do you have is there
a book that you're reading right now
yeah i'm reading right now really yeah
you read it before you go to bed
sometimes yeah on the kindle i'm a
kindle guy i don't like having the book
what book you're reading right now i'm
i've never read 48 laws of power so i'm
reading 48 laws of power how to kill
cicada killers
[Laughter]
48 laws of 48 48 laws of power is a
really interesting book i'd have never
it's like it's so
popular
like it's sold so many copies you read
it and this guy's like teaching you how
to be a psychopath it's hilarious why's
there so many bozos out there so popular
that's what i want to know the secret
what are we talking about here yeah it's
like the secret and 48 laws of power i
think it's because american like america
is like eluding we're all here to loot
our parents came here to loot we don't
share any common culture anything every
immigrant came here to loot just show
what they can do yes you just get the
bag
secrets like how do you get rich and 48
laws of power is like how do you control
people everyone's here to just [ __ ]
loot and like it's like a casino
everyone's trying to [ __ ] hit that
lotto that's patreon.com folks
all the bonus content you desire
yeah you know um all right let's do
let's do two more this is from chuck
barry dinger shout out you or anyone in
your family say mcdonald's
mcdonald's m-a-c-k donald mcdonald's
mcdonald's that's more of a black dang i
go to mcdonald's okay yeah i've had
black friends to be like go to
mcdonald's y'all go to mcdonald's
well you're
yeah how great the guy the founder right
you saw that movie yeah of course loved
that [ __ ] he knew it was all about
that name some guys are so good at the
marketing thing he's like i need that
name donald he played like i watched him
all the time such a good and hating like
hateful character like you like you
hated that guy but it was great it was
awesome yeah when he tells his wife he
wants a divorce he's [ __ ] he just
does it so perfectly yeah just real
quiet he's eating his carrots he knows
he's gotten to a certain point where
there's no going back and [ __ ] she
can't do anything when it's over yeah
yeah all for that [ __ ] homewrecker
milkshakes
um
all right let's see
this is from colleen uh first time long
time have you ever sold a product that
required a demonstration from colleen
you got a lot of 60 year old listeners
that's not you you look at the registry
that one's not a hot ticket
colleen said what
i like how he heard colleen that he just
started trashing her wait hold on you're
saying have you ever sold
yeah have you ever sold or i guess or
bought for conversation purposes a
product that required a demonstration
like i used to i so i did sell
uh these are good questions uh cause
they're always shitty prod like the cut
go knives or yeah i did like a soda like
a knockoff soda stream yeah i sold uh
new bank accounts to uh incoming
students as one of my jobs at college
wow that kind of came with a pseudo
demonstration where was at the bank
where were you like on campus at the
bank on campus step right up step right
up right up a little yeah you like how
how it works debit cards all that with
new kids to get them to sign up
was there anything you were giving away
a lot of times it would be like sure
yeah t-shirt little keychain and guess
what what was the best rosie for the cop
there you go cozy for the cup was it
what was the bank uh it was called
industrial bank of washington
yeah so i don't know if it sounds like a
union yeah
i don't think it was one of the big boys
but it might have been i don't know is
industrial mega washington who knows but
that's what it's called yeah industrial
bank of washington arena
for the mud hands play yeah it's where
kids play hockey it sounds like a shell
cup yeah yeah [ __ ]
it was just you
it's just me out there yeah i mean the
bank was like it was like why's the
address the dorm room
welcome to the industrial bank of
washington i just came out with a
written name tag
the honest passion
president and ceo
and also junior sales executive
those lollipops are free
oh and there was lollipops
you get a sucker to do anything with a
couple dumb dumbs i'll tell you that
right now it was lollipop i'll sign it
for scientology if they got a couple of
root beer dum-dums
oh there was a ray of stuff now i
remember there was a button too
it was a button okay yeah yeah i had a
lot of goodies
yeah he only broke them out if you were
if you had someone on the line he wasn't
gonna
listen i'm not supposed to do this but
i can throw in this pin
account too yeah i'll throw in the
magnet all right you're a good kid
ladies and gentlemen mr giannis papa's
host of long days special out right now
called mom love do yourself a favor
johnny anything you want the folks out
there to know yeah dates website
anything yeah everything uh i will be uh
uncle vinnie's in uh point please with
new jersey september 9th and 10th so get
tickets for that working on a whole new
uh you know hour of comedy please do
watch the special uh mom love um it's
it's drop some comments too get that
algorithm
tell them ayg sent ya
please do uh share it with your friends
it seems to be well received i think
you'll enjoy it 100 fantastic buddy we
love you appreciate it thank you so much
for coming in kippy what do we got for
him again our road shows tickets are
really starting to [ __ ] cook uh get
them tickets before it's too late thanks
for the support we love yous we love you
and we'll see you next week peace